éclore et progresser donc tout ce qui
pourra aller dans ce sens là ça sera
bien
faciliter le financement
faciliter je dirais tout ce qui peut
toucher ou à la croissance des
entreprises ça sera toujours utile
maintenant maintenant je dirais c'est à
ce gouvernement de faire ses propres
choix et
après on verra une fois qu'ils seront
exprimés pour relancer la compétitivité
et l'emploi le gouvernement aura retenu
parce qu'on va devoir finalement avancer
la trésorerie pendant une année pour
récupérer donc en 2013 éventuellement un
crédit d'impôt sur les dépenses
supplémentaires qu'on aura faites cette
année alors c'est vraiment une
compétitivité maintenant dont on a
besoin de rien un coup maintenant
d'autres la trésorerie et non pas de
dépenser plus pour retrouver
hypothétiquement une compétitivité dans
le prochain même son de cloche du côté
du Medef le gouvernement demande un
rapport avec des mesures simples qui
peut taper immédiatement on a
l'impression qu'on a d'un grand
marchandage quand même parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on les payera en
déduction fiscale sur deux ou trois ans
l'impact ne sera pas produit
immédiatement et l'impact sera produit
que dans deux ans trois ans donc c'est
pas une mauvaise mesure mais c'est une
demi mesure
pour vous